This morning
Ukrainian forces
destroying all ten missiles,
a targeting key.
Also reporting, however, that falling
debris has resulted
in the deaths of a nine year old girl.
Her mother and another woman.
Ukraine's
minister of internal affairs
says all three deaths were tied.
All three, rather,
tried to enter a bomb shelter
that was closed
You may recall
Russian President Vladimir Putin has
said he launched this invasion
to stop Naito from getting closer
to the Russian border.
Now NATO's
secretary general
Stoltenberg says
that is exactly what will happen
as late as last year.
All the allies agreed
that Ukraine will become a member
of this alliance.
And and we are making
concrete steps because Ukraine is moving
towards NATO's
meaning that they are coming
closer and closer,
meaning that they are
moving from the Soviet standards
to NATO's standards, equipment, doctrines
and we are helping them
doing that as we speak.
CNN's Sam
Kiley joining us this morning
live in eastern
Ukraine with more on this.
So first, Sam,
let's talk about those attacks
overnight on key.
What more are we learning
Well, we understand, Erica,
that these
ten missiles were shot down
over the Ukrainian capital
after a brief sort of nearly
a day long lull in which
there have been no attacks.
That was the first day
that there had been no attacks, more
or less for about two weeks
in the Ukrainian capital,
which has been the focus of attention
of the Russian bombardment.
But tragically, three people killed
and a number.
Well, they were all killed
and a large number injured
when they found themselves
locked out of a significant bunker.
Now, these are Soviet era bunkers
that are built around the city
very frequently close
to underneath
the tower blocks in a residential blocks.
But for reasons
that are now subject
of an
official investigation
in Kiev, more than a year after the war,
somebody had locked the door,
trapping people outside.
And then tragically,
they were hit by debris
descending this hill, coming on a day
in which the Russians continue
to be under pressure to,
they are saying in Belgorod Province
in the south of Russia,
on the northern border with Ukraine, that
a large number of villages along
the border are being evacuated.
More than 300 children,
they're talking about evacuating,
evacuating women.
And that's because a number of towns,
they claim
are being hit
currently with Ukrainian artillery
and mortars.
And this is now part of a new pattern
of cross-border
operations being conducted by Ukraine.
Into Russia.
They had been extremely rare in the past.
Now they're becoming more routines.
You're seeing a lot more of this
tit for tat effects
on civilians
on both sides of this conflict.
So there's the tit for tat aspect of it.
And then there is also
what we could potentially see
on the heels of these comments
from Stoltenberg,
saying that NATO's members agree
Ukraine should be a member.
What is the sense
this morning
in terms
of what that could prompt
in terms of attacks from Russia?
I don't think the
Russians have
a great deal in their armory
that would be
deployed in some kind of response to this
sort of event.
It's always a mistake
to think that people,
when they're prosecuting
a war,
will react to anniversaries
or retaliate in kind for certain acts.
They prosecute,
prosecuting an ongoing campaign here.
They will use this
statement coming from you and Stoltenberg
domestically in the Kremlin
to kind of prove their point
to the Russian population
that they needed to go to war
to prevent Naito doing just this.
And then it'll be up to the Russians
to decide whether or not
the Ukraine's closeness
to Naito is a consequence
of the Russian invasion
rather than anything else.
Sam Kiley
live for us in Ukraine this morning.
Thank you.
A new front
opening in Moscow's war on Ukraine
with cross-border attacks
bringing the battle
to the Russian people.
Meantime, a terrifying night in Kiev.
The mayor
there says
at least three people are dead.
14 injured in missile
strikes on the capital.
It follows days of artillery attacks
just inside Russia.
The governor of the Belgorod
region says
hundreds of women and children
are being evacuated now.
CNN's Clare Sebastian is live in London.
And Clare,
Kiev is not claiming responsibility
for those attacks,
but could this be
a turning point in the war?
If it's a turning point?
It's not clear just yet, Christine,
but it does feel like
this is a new phase in the war.
We have seen sporadic
shelling over the border
in the Belgorod region
since the beginning,
but the uptick has been significant
in recent days and weeks.
As you said,
more shelling reported this morning.
A number of injuries
reported by the governor there.
The impact as well on people
living there with
with the constant
threat of injury and death.
Children, as you say, in the hundreds
being evacuated this morning.
We had
they've canceled
sort of state school exams because of
the violence there.
So it is impacting people in that region.
The Kremlin has called the situation
rather alarming.
And separately this morning,
Christine,
we're hearing from
both of those two groups
who were responsible for that
pretty violent incursion into Belgorod.
Just a week or so ago.
One of them says
they are already back on Russian soil.
The other says
they're close to the border.
We've not been able to verify this.
And the governor of the Belgorod
region says that the enemy
is not on his territory at the moment.
But they, as you
remember, were responsible
for really the first bout
that we've seen of actual physical
fighting on Russian soil
since the beginning of this war.
So clearly, this is a new phase.
It's not just Belgorod.
We've seen repeated
drone attacks
as far north as the Barents region,
which is north of Kiev,
down to Krasnodar.
Two oil refineries affected on Wednesday.
So this war
that was already being
fought over a very wide area,
it seems that the scope has now widened
even further. Christine.
And the Ukrainian government
is not taking responsibility, right?
They are not explicitly
taking responsibility
but certainly
there have been hints
of presidential adviser
calling,
for example,
the drone attack on Moscow,
Russia's karmic payment,
and promising
more attacks
like this, but explicitly
no claim of responsibility.
And the U.S.
Pentagon has said
it is counterproductive to be
to be attacking inside Russia.
All right.
Clare Sebastian, thank you so much.